season number two of bachelor in
paradise wraps up this Sunday and Monday
on ABC now before the first episode even
aired our Ashlyn cousteau was the only
reporter invited behind the scenes in
Mexico I will say I'm a little jealous
and now she has clues to how this is all
going to end now
did you find love I definitely found
some intense life while Ashley is known
as this season's virgin she fell hard
for Jared
so is intense like enough to do the deed
it was crazy about the wait-and-see and
I don't know what's gonna happen tonight
but I may not be a virgin tomorrow
ABC's finale promo calls it like it is
so the virgin go all the way in the
fantasy suite tonight's a huge diet
Juris taking my virginity but has TV
dating gone too far by making light of a
serious situation what I say about my
portray on The Bachelor is that was a
caricature of myself it's like the
Virgin thing was brought up all the time
I'm like I have like a heart and soul of
evil like I go beyond all that image
stuff my first serious relationship will
probably be my husband
well Ashley and Jared find love or
breakup oh my gosh there are plenty of
Tears to go around I hate I hate I hate
him and a new arrival brings chaos to
paradise this is definitely the first
guy that I've met that I can fall in
love it
bachelor in paradise is on our roll the
ratings have been going up each week to
score new highs for the series now
nothing's been announced yet but it
sounds like it's a good bet that we're
going to be seeing a season three